la marge de manoeuvre se resserre pour
des constructeurs d'immeubles à
logements frappé par l'explosion des
coûts des matériaux quelqu'un qui achète
un intérêt présentement avec une
beaucoup de constructions et les taux
d'intérêt qui sont en hausse c'est sûr
que les chiffons un peu moins de sens
qui le faisaient à eux deux
le groupe firman qui met en chantier 200
logements par année terminent la
construction d'un immeuble de 52 unités
locatives à saint zotique les coûts du
projet d'une quinzaine de millions de
dollars ont bondi de 20% depuis le début
des travaux pour être sur ce
qui va être là lorsqu'ils vont à bord
d'un jeep s'adapter 200 mille dollars de
plus et les exemples s'enchaînent ce
félin ici je peux vous montrer simple
fil stades a augmenté de 280 pour ça les
deux propriétaires ont dû eux aussi leur
loyer de 8 à 10% par rapport aux
prévisions initiales
on fait attention vous propose aussi
augmenter les loyers parce que les coûts
de construction augmente pour couvrir le
manque à gagner ils se sont tournés vers
un nouveau programme d'assurance prêt de
la société canadienne d'hypothèques et
de logement à péage select permet
d'étirer l'amortissement jusqu'à 50 ans
et de payer une prime réduite à
condition d'offrir des unités abordables
accessibles et efficaces sur le plan
énergétique firman est en attente
d'approbation neuf logements seront
offerts à 30% du revenu médian des
locataires donc abordable mais sans
programme et aurait fallu
potentiellement faire revoir que le
poids de la peur peut-être ralenti la
quantité de logements qu on a à
construire dans les prochaines années
il faut lutter être reporter certains
projets par le scénario idéal alors
qu'il manque 100 mille logements au
québec
la schl espère ainsi pouvoir stimuler la
création de logements abordables
malgré la conjoncture
des demandes des centaines de nos
membres sont entre
les coûts de construction n'épargne pas
le logement social non plus les 70000 $
par porte prévu dans le dernier budget
du québec pour compléter 3500 unités
seraient insuffisants
quadrature du cercle
qui va obliger certains à des décisions
assez dramatique rien n'indique que les
prix des matériaux sont sur le point de
se stabiliser la demande tant privés que
publics demeurent vigoureuses et si
mathieu dion radio canada montréal